il ne s'agit pas d'un refus de prendre
en compte la situation particulière des
retraités agricoles
mais le gouvernement considère
aujourd'hui que les conditions qui le
permettrait ne sont pas réunies et que
légiférer aujourd'hui serait prématuré
le gouvernement entend prendre ses
responsabilités j'ai l'honneur en
conséquence de vous informer qu'en
application de l'article 44 alinéa 3 de
la constitution et de l'article 42
alinéa 7 du règlement du sénat le
gouvernement demande à la haute
assemblée de se prononcer par un seul
vote sur l'ensemble du texte
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît la parole est à madame
la ministre
[Musique]
sur l'ensemble du texte
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je vous demande de vous
calmer que sur l'article 1er est
l'amendement numéro 3 je vous remercie